sources tell CBS News the White House
and intelligence agencies are discussing
ways to allow the whistleblower to share
information in the original complaint
with lawmakers Paula Reid is with us
this morning Paula the complaint led to
questions about what delayed this aid
for Ukraine what's the president saying
on that point
it's amazing Tony over the past 24 hours
the president's story has completely
changed at first on Monday he said that
this aid was delayed because he was
concerned about corruption he wanted to
make sure the new Ukrainian leader was
committed to anti-corruption reforms but
then yesterday he shifted his
explanation and said no in fact he
wanted to make sure the US wasn't the
only country putting up money and it's
interesting and talking to sources at
the White House it's getting harder and
harder to get people to talk about the
reason this was delayed because they
don't want to get out ahead of the
president suggesting something is not on
the up-and-up can you help us help
everybody understand why it actually
matters if the President did in fact use
his political capital to get information
against a political opponent it's
remarkable that after the president was
investigated for two years over possibly
colluding with a foreign power in a US
election that he would even entertain
anything related to a political rival
but again his defense and the
administration sources they tell me that
there's no quid pro quo here they say
look if we release the transcript which
we expect they will do it will exonerate
the president there was nothing explicit
but what we've seen with the president
in these previous criminal
investigations because he is a way of
kind of pressuring people to do things
that are inappropriate without
explicitly saying it and that's what
makes it a little complicated
what do you think they make of the calls
for an impeachment at the White House so
far all the sources I'm calling mostly
legal folks it's a shrug they believe in
impeachment inquiry well what is that
why would we have to cooperate any more
than we already have which is pretty
much the bare minimum required under the
law they believe that Democrats have
overstepped they think they'll be
exonerated by this transcript we may see
that later today and it'll be up to
folks to look at that and decide to
themselves
all right Paula thank you